robert kraft who usually does media
availability in conjunction with the
league meetings when they are in person
had a conference call with reporters
today
and he said among other things that he
trusts bill belichick's ability to build
a football team now drafting and
developing i don't know that i would
trust that but the first time ever we've
seen the patriots jump aggressively into
free agency having more caps based
relative to the other teams than except
maybe two or three i think they were
third in total cap space going into this
season where the cap was about 25
million less than it would have been
kraft signed off on it and belichick did
it went out there and rounded up a bunch
of guys in an effort to make the team
better shireen and as kraft said to
peter king a couple of weeks ago
this is what the patriots used to make
fun of teams for doing spending like
this right out of the gates in free
agency and now for the first time in the
era of free agency at least under
ownership by the crafts this is what the
patriots did
i remember a few years ago i talked to
robert craft for a story i was doing for
the super bowl game program about
their dynasty and what they were going
to do post dynasty however they were
going to keep that going and he was
convinced that because of bill belichick
they wouldn't have any down years that
they would just keep this dynasty going
forever that obviously didn't happen but
i was a little bit impressed with what
they did last season with the roster
they had mike winning seven games with
that roster was a feat
and i think they've improved the talent
on the team to me it still goes back to
the quarterback though i don't know what
the
future is at that position i know robert
kraft today
expressed confidence in jarrett stidham
and said we just haven't seen enough to
know well i would agree with that but
you didn't make him your quarterback
last year when you had a chance to
and it does look like you're going to
make him your quarterback this year so i
would have serious doubts about whether
jarrett stidham is your quarterback of
the future so they still have to find
that quarterback of the future because
it's probably not going to be cam newton
considering his age and his injury
history
craft addressed cam newton's performance
last year and said in fairness to cam
i'm not sure he had the proper weapons
around him
last year take that
remaining members of the patriots who
were the weapons around cam newton last
year the boss doesn't think you were
very good don't don't buy rent heading
into 2021 but i think more than anything
else that cova diagnosis screwed up cam
newton i thought he was solid early in
the season i was fascinated by what they
were doing to develop an offense for him
josh mcdaniel is using the tebow offense
that mcdaniels had prepared in denver
for the inevitable ascension of tebow to
the top of the depth chart of course by
the time it happened mcdaniels had been
fired but he still had developed the
offense for use by tim tebow and
newton's a better runner a better passer
a better everything than tebow was i
think that coveted situation screwed
everything up for newton and in turn for
the patriots and now you put better
weapons around him you look at the guys
they've brought in
i i and that they won seven games with a
team that was so bad
plenty of reason for optimism this year
for the new england patriots shireen
well you know mike we've seen these
dream team scenarios you know i keep
going back the eagles in 2011 when they
were supposed to have this dream team
they did this in free agency and
obviously went eight and eight that
season didn't have the dream team they
thought
every time we see a team load up with
free agents it doesn't seem to work but
if it's gonna work anywhere it's gonna
work with bill belichick right he picked
his kind of guys some of them have
already been with the patriots before
like kyle van noy and have come home
to roost again so if it's going to work
anywhere it's going to work in new
england and i do think they've upgraded
the talent there in new england they
spent what the last time i checked it
was the second most guaranteed money in
the history of free agency that they had
given out and i don't know what the case
is now they may be number one by now
shoot who knows but they spent a lot of
money we can all agree on that and
signed a lot of free agents to try to
help this team win more games this
season and i think if you're the bills
you look at them a little bit now
thinking all right you know have we
improved enough in the off season to
stay ahead of what the patriots have
done
and you look at what the dolphins are
doing you look at what the jets may do
with the presumed acquisition of zack
wilson afc east very very good division
and i'm all in with you on the idea that
that eagles team in 2011 loaded up
created expectations the ill-advised
comment by
vince young that it's a dream team the
groans came from philadelphia at least
from the front office the moment he said
it but remember in 2011 that was when
free agency began in august and there
was a lot of deck shuffling that
happened then this time at least they've
got the guys under the tent months in
advance to really work it up and i think
with bill belichick the more time you
give him
with a team
the better the team's going to be and
that's why belichick probably hoping to
get plenty of time with these guys on
the field in the offseason we'll talk
more about the plan for the off-season
program
coming up seven and nine was the record
as we mentioned last year for the new
england patriots and robert craft was
asked about going 7-9 how did i feel he
said i'm not going to use the word
but it was horrible what do we think the
word was shireen like shh
i would say would be the beginning of it
i think that would be
that would probably be my guess because
that's that's probably the right feeling
i think we're live well i think we're
live on sky sports right so we can't say
it today mike
now i don't think we're live on sky
sports in the off season or not yeah but
just during the season i actually think
we can't say it anyway we can't say it
on peacock either even though even
though i've watched plenty of shows and
movies on peacock and the language is
not pg by the way i don't know why we're
restricted russell crowe can say the f
word i can't say the f word i got a
problem with that who does russell crowe
think he is all due respect uh but
anyway uh actually right now on sky
is the pft live show from today so
instead of taking us live in the
afternoon
the folks at sky got a deal with me and
sims from earlier today um
so anyway look we both are on the same
page patriots compelling interesting a
great laboratory experiment whatever it
does it's going to be
memorable it's going to be significant
and it's going to be fun to watch and
you throw in on top of everything else
we haven't talked about this
the idea that that extra game hosting
the dallas cowboys your cowboys this
year just another compelling moment and
opportunity for the patriots with all
these new players to show what they can
do i have a feeling
cowboys at patriots will occupy a prime
time slot somewhere
oh there's no doubt about that mike it
will be on prime time probably on nbc on
sunday night football and we can all
look forward to that game and i would
bet it's toward the the beginning of the
season rather the end of the season
because you don't know how either one of
these teams are going to shake out this
year
that's true don't hold back some of
these games where you've got health
questions with key players because it
could end up being a monday night game
that gets flexed out on monday night to
sunday although i don't think the flex
is starting this year i think that
starts in 20 23.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports